Bolivia, ojo, es el único país del mundo donde
la popular cadena de hamburguesas, McDonalds,
sin lugar a dudas uno de los símbolos de
la globalización, ha quebrado.
Tras poco más de 5 años de operaciones,
sus ocho restaurantes en el país tuvieron
que cerrar sus puertas en 2002 porque, simplemente,
los bolivianos pasaron de ellos.
Vamos que casi podemos decir que para muchos hoy Bolivia es algo así como la aldea de
Asterix y Obelix, un rincón del mundo que
se resiste contra viento y marea a lo que
esta misma gente llama el imperialismo cultural
de la globalización y las grandes potencias
occidentales.
Precisamente, el Presidente boliviano, Evo
Morales, el primer Presidente indígena en
toda la historia de Latinoamérica, es un
claro exponente de esta forma de pensar.
Su hostilidad hacia todo lo que tiene que
ver con el capitalismo alcanza tal nivel, ojo,
que se jacta de llevar más de 5 años sin
tomar un solo vaso de Coca Cola.
Pero bueno, más allá, amigos, de este tipo de historias
anecdóticas, lo cierto es que el discurso
de
Evo Morales es uno de los más beligerantes
contra el libre mercado, la globalización
y los sistemas políticos occidentales.
- "El vivir bien o el buen vivir como dice nuestro hermano Presidente de Ecuador,
eso es la síntesis del socialismo comunitario.
y el vivir mejor es la síntesis del capitalismo, hay una profunda diferencia
De hecho, a día de hoy casi podemos decir
que Evo Morales es el último líder de ese
ciclo de izquierdas que dio
comienzo a principios del S.XXI y que hasta
hace muy poquito ha dominado la política
latinoamericana.
Me refiero a líderes como Hugo Chávez y
Maduro en Venezuela, Kischer en Argentina,
Lula y Dilma Rouseff en Brasil o, por supuesto,
Rafael Correa en Ecuador.
De todos ellos, a día de hoy, solo sobreviven
liderando la política nacional de sus respectivos
países Evo Morales y Nicolás Maduro, claro
que en circunstancias muy diferentes:
mientras en Venezuela el desastre es prácticamente
total, el país casi ha quebrado,
Bolivia ha sido durante los últimos tres
años el país que más ha crecido de Latinoamérica.
Esto ha hecho que Evo prácticamente conserve
intactas sus altísimas cotas de popularidad
y reconocimiento internacional, al tiempo que para muchos, seguramente también muchos de vosotros, se ha convertido en el gran referente
de la izquierda que aspira en sus propias
palabras a terminar con la globalización
imperialista dominada por las grandes multinacionales.
El resultado es que, para muchos, empezando
por el mismo, Evo Morales es un líder indiscutible,
un ejemplo a seguir:
Para otros, en cambio, no es más que otro líder populista
que está cercenando las libertades civiles
y conduciendo a su país al desastre.
Pero ¿Cuál es la verdad?
¿Cómo está realmente Bolivia?
¿Ha logrado de verdad Evo Morales el boom
económico que se le atribuye?
Estas son algunas de las preguntas a las que
vamos a contestar en este vídeo, pero, antes
de nada, echemos un vistazo atrás, a la historia,
para que veamos donde comenzó todo.
Bolivia, amigos, es un país increíblemente rico en
recursos naturales: Oro, plata, estaño, hierro,
Gas Natural, Petróleo e incluso litio, muchísimo
litio. Y ojo porque este es uno de los recursos
naturales más cotizados en nuestros días.
¿Habéis oído hablar del salar de Uyuni?
Ese impresionante océano de color blanco
que atrae a gente de todo el mundo en busca
de una foto perfecta, casi propia de otro
planeta.
Pues bien, tras esa brillante capa de sal
que cubre su superficie se encuentran una
de las mayores reservas de litio del mundo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a día de hoy,
las reservas estimadas de Litio de Bolivia
tendrían un valor de mercado de cerca de
80.000 millones de dólares, casi tres veces
todo el PIB del país.
Y a todo ello hay que sumar el resto: gas,
petróleo, oro… vamos un despliegue impresionante
de riquezas.
Como dicen también en Perú, este país está sentado sobre un trono de oro.
A pesar de ello, amigos de VisualPolitik,
Bolivia es hoy, y ha sido tradicionalmente
uno de los países más pobres de toda Latinoamérica.
Fijaros, a inicios del S.XXI, prácticamente antes de ayer, el ingreso por habitante de Bolivia era similar al de la
República Democrática del Congo.
Con todo, podemos decir que los 80 fueron la década más dolorosa: Tras unos convulsos
años 70, dominados por continuos golpes de
estado y regímenes militares, que
endeudaron al país hasta las cejas y destruyeron prácticamente cualquier actividad productiva,
la caída del precio del Estaño, que por aquel entonces
era la mayor exportación del país, hundió
a Bolivia en una crisis brutal.
Por si fuese poco, la respuesta del gobierno
de izquierdas de la Unión Democrática y
Popular, que lideró el Presidente Hernán
Siles Zuazo, fue tan mala que el país cayó
en una hiperinflación descomunal de más del 25.000% en apenas unos años
y retrocedió, atentos, 30 años en términos de desarrollo.
Ojo ¡Hasta 2008 Bolivia no recuperó la renta
media que tenía en 1977!
Ante este desolador panorama, el gobierno convocó
en 1985, apenas dos años y medio después
de tomar el poder, elecciones, que esta vez llevaron a la Presidencia a Victor Paz Estenssoro, que ya había
sido Presidente en tres ocasiones anteriores.
- "La primera tarea que va a emprender el nuevo gobierno
es poner freno al proceso de crisis que está viviendo el país.
¡Vamos a enfrentarnos a la crisis!".
A partir de ese momento,  y durante
prácticamente toda la década de los 90, los diferentes
gobiernos bolivianos, y sobre todo el encabezado
por el Presidente Sánchez de Lozada, pusieron
en marcha reformas muy importantes, impulsadas,
por cierto, por el FMI y el BM, por cierto, que tenían
por objetivo dotar a Bolivia de una economía
competitiva de mercado.
Así que en estos años se sucedieron las privatizaciones, se liberalizaron muchísimos
aspectos de la economía, se combatió el déficit fiscal, se redujeron los aranceles…
¿Suena bonito, ¿verdad?
El problema es que las reformas no consiguieron superar ni la corrupción ni el capitalismo de
amiguetes.
Es verdad que se lograron muchos avances,
la economía se estabilizó y creció una
media del 4% al año durante los 90, pero
esto era claramente insuficiente para sacar
al país de la pobreza y desde luego era un
crecimiento muy inferior al que registraban
muchos países emergentes, por ejemplo, en Asia.
Sin seguridad jurídica y sin competencia
poco había que hacer.
Es decir, me explico, no es que los planteamientos fuesen erróneo, ni muchísimo menos, el problema
fue que la implantación, que la puesta en marcha de estas reformas fue simplemente horrible.
Por supuesto, como ocurre casi siempre, cuando se reforma algo tiene un coste social, por ejemplo, muchos mineros
y campesinos minifundistas perdieron su trabajo y se vieron obligados a emigrar a las ciudades.
Pero claro, la falta de resultados visibles
generó muchísima frustración social.
Por así decirlo, hubo muchas promesas y pocos resultados.
Y tal vez os preguntéis ¿Cual fue la gota que colmó el vaso?
Pues en este caso no fue responsabilidad de Bolivia, sino de sus vecinos:
Las crisis argentinas y brasileñas de principio
de siglo acabaron por derrumbar cualquier
signo de prosperidad. El país exportaba a estos países y como estos estaban pasando una crisis brutal...
Entre 1999 y 2003 la economía boliviana no
creció nada.
¿Un país tan pobre incapaz de crecer?
Algo falla ¿verdad?, el modelo no puede ser bueno.
Bolivia ha sido siempre un gran productor
de planta de coca, que tradicionalmente en
los países andinos se utiliza como goma de
mascar y también para hacer infusiones.
Sin embargo, esta planta también tiene un
uso mucho más lucrativo: la producción de
cocaína, la droga ilegal que más dinero
mueve del mundo.
Pues bien, en los años 80 y 90, Estados Unidos
ya se encontraba en plena Guerra contra las
drogas, y presionaba y pagaba a los gobiernos
latinoamericanos para que destruyeran los
cultivos.
El problema es que esto implicaba dejar sin
trabajo y arruinar a decenas de miles de familias.
Eso es precisamente lo que ocurrió en Bolivia,
muchos campesinos vieron como el gobierno
iniciaba una guerra contra los productores
cocaleros y destruía sus plantaciones,
así que ya os podéis imaginar el cabreo monumental
de esta población.
Pensad que este era un negocio que generaba mucho dinero: sólo en 1986 las ventas de cocaína igualaban
a todas las exportaciones legales del país.
Desde luego, los campesinos cocaleros no se
quedaron de brazos cruzados, se agruparon
en sindicatos y recurrieron a una continua
movilización: manifestaciones, cortes de
carreteras, bloqueos...
Pero esto no es todo, aun hay más. En Bolivia, la población de origen indígena, que es la casi la mitad
del total, estuvo tradicionalmente excluida
del poder político.
Es decir, de facto, Bolivia era un país muy
racista… pero no con una minoría sino contra la mayoría de su población.
¡De locos!
Bien ya tenemos los tres factores clave que
impulsaron al MAS, al Movimiento al Socialismo,
el partido al cual pertenece Evo Morales, que era el
instrumento político que desarrollaron los
sindicatos campesinos, los representantes cocaleros, fundamentalmente.
Crisis y frustración económica; Guerra contra
la coca y racismo.
Precisamente, estos fueron los pilares de un partido, el MAS, que arrasó en las elecciones de 2005 obteniendo
una inédita mayoría absoluta, que no solo mantuvo sino que incluso incrementó en 2009 y en 2014.
La primera gran medida de Evo fue nacionalizar
el sector de los hidrocarburos, y lo hizo
además a lo grande, ordenando al ejército
ocupar los yacimientos de gas.
Aunque lo cierto, casi siempre hay una historia entre bastidores,
es que más allá de las fotos, lo que se hizo no fue sino renegociar
los contratos de explotación conforme a una
ley ya aprobada antes de la llegada de Evo.
Pero bueno, el caso es que el gobierno boliviano con las reformas multiplicó la renta petrolera, es
decir lo que recauda con la explotación de
petróleo y el gas natural.
El gobierno pasó de llevarse algo menos de un
20% de los ingresos a más del 80%, justo
además, en el momento que daba comienzo el llamado superciclo de las meterías primas y los hidrocarburos
que multiplicaron sus precios.
Y esto no es todo, por si fuese poco, en 2005, poco antes de la llegada de Evo al poder, tanto el BM como
el FMI decidieron condonar la deuda externa que Bolivia tenía contraído con ellos, de
un plumazo el país se liberó del 35% de
toda la deuda exterior.
Y claro estos dos factores fueron auténtica gasolina para los gobiernos de Evo Morales,
que contaron con recursos públicos como nunca antes había tenido el gobierno de Bolivia.
En cierto modo esto explica la evolución
tan positiva que ha tenido la economía boliviana durante estos años.
Ojo, es verdad que el gobierno de Evo Morales
ha hecho cosas relativamente bien: por ejemplo,
de todos los gobiernos de izquierdas en Latinoamérica,
que antes hemos mencionado, ha sido el más
prudente a la hora de gastar, de hecho, ha
reducido la deuda pública y ha acumulado
ahorros importantes.
También ha apostado mucho por la inversión en un país sin prácticamente infraestructuras
y ha contribuido enormemente a la cohesión
social con la integración de los pueblos
indígenas.
Bueno ¡Él mismo es un aymara!
Pero un momento, antes de que os abalancéis sobre mi, esperad, porque la historia no ha acabado aquí.
Una cosa es que haya hecho las cosas mejor
que los gobiernos de Chavez, Maduro, Correa
o Kischner y otra muy distinta es que las
cosas se hayan hecho bien.
Es verdad que desde que está el poder el
país ha crecido una media del 5% cada año y que la pobreza
se ha reducido la mitad, pero es que en cuando
los precios del petróleo y las materias primas
cayeron empezaron los problemas:
El país es hoy más dependiente de los recursos naturales que cuando Evo Morales llegó al poder,
y eso desde luego no es algo positivo, de
hecho, hoy en Bolivia las Importaciones son
mayores que las exportaciones.
El déficit público real del gobierno en 2016 pudo superar la friolera del 8%, la inversión privada
es muy, muy reducida y según el Doing Business es uno de los peores países para hacer negocios.
Fijaros, en Nueva Zelanda, un país que ya sabeos nos encanta,  solo se requiere un trámite para iniciar un negocio y se tarda
medio día en hacerlo, el coste es ridículo.
En Bolivia, en cambio, son necesarios 50 días, 15 trámites y, ojo,  siete meses de los ingresos promedios de montar
una empresa.
¿De verdad alguien piensa que haciendo tan
complicado montar negocios un país puede
prosperar?
Y luego está también el problema del narcotráfico:
Y ojo, que nadie se equivoque, Bolivia sigue
siendo hoy uno de los 3 países más pobres
de Sudamérica.
Tal vez todo esto, junto a la aparición de
sospechas de corrupción, ciertas promesas incumplidas,
la poca confianza que ha promovido y algunos gestos
como este:
Propiciaran la primera gran derrota del MAS:
en febrero de 2016 se llevó a cabo un referéndum
que tenía por objeto cambiar la constitución
para permitir que Evo se presentase a un tercer
mandato consecutivo: ganó el no.
Aun así Parece que Evo sigue empeñado…
Bueno tu qué piensas ¿Cuál es tu opinión
sobre el gobierno de Evo Morales?
¿Crees que Evo acatará la Constitución
o tratará de aferrarse al poder?
Espero que este vídeo te haya resultado interesante,
si ha sido así
y quieres que hablamos más de Bolivia, de Evo Morales y de otros políticos latinoamericanos.
no te olvides de darle al botón like para hacérnoslo saber. Y por supuesto si aun no lo has hecho suscríbete al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima, amigos.